you have to get your wisdom teeth
removed okay
big myth here
charcoal toothpaste is better than
regular toothpaste no
no no no there is no such thing as
brushing too much try to brush for at
least two minutes right sing twinkle
twinkle little star what i feel like
that's so short no like sick the whole
verse hey everyone my name is dr amina
saeed i'm a dentist working out of the
chicagoland area and my name is dr
aliyah pringle elim also a dentist and
we are here to debunk some dental myths
myth number one sugar causes cavities oh
my gosh sugar actually is not the cause
of cavities in your mouth you have
active normal bacteria and when sugar is
fed to that bacteria the bacteria
produces acid and it creates cavities on
teeth so it's the fuel for the bacteria
to cause the cavities myth two
electric toothbrushes are better than
regular toothbrushes the most important
thing is that you are actually brushing
right so having that mechanical movement
against your teeth whether it be an
electric toothbrush a regular toothbrush
that's the most important thing to
prevent plaque from sitting on the
surfaces of our teeth so if you have a
regular toothbrush you can still do a
good job of brushing at home
myth number three
white teeth are always healthy white
teeth really just have to do with how
your enamel appears on the surface so
your tooth actually has three layers it
has the inside core which is the pulp it
has that middle layer which is yellow in
color and then it has enamel which shows
up wider it's like the armor of your
tooth so genetically speaking if you
don't have the type of teeth that will
appear wider after whitening you'll have
to go maybe veneers or crowns to get a
wider wider wider smile it's very
possible to have you know cavities bone
loss periodontal disease even with
pearly white teeth all right myth number
four there's no such thing as brushing
too much
any time you want to take plaque off
your teeth
we're all for it but it then it comes to
how hard are you brushing right some
people go in there and it's like a
chainsaw they're just
and what ends up happening is when you
break down that enamel by so much so
much hard and vigorous brushing you end
up getting sensitivity so people are
like oh i drink something and my teeth
hurt so when you look at your toothbrush
and if the bristles are flared out like
this
you're doing it too hard myth number
five drinking with a straw is better for
your teeth this is kind of true but also
kind of false so
drinking through a straw
is theoretically better for your teeth
if done the right way
so if you drink through the straw and
the liquid literally just passes from
the straw maybe to your tongue to your
throat and you swallowed and that's okay
but the problem comes with when people
drink through the straw and they still
kind of swish it around in their mouths
that kind of defeats the purpose of
drinking through the straw it's damaging
your teeth the longer that that liquid
sits on your teeth so drink it fast if
you can
drink it through a straw the right way
if you can
and always always always follow it up
with water if you can follow up your
acidic drinks with water you can help
your body get your ph back down to
neutral or back up to neutral quicker
myth six
brushing harder makes your teeth cleaner
okay if brushing harder does not make
your teeth cleaner what makes your teeth
cleaner is effective brushing if you're
brushing the right way right if i take
my toothbrush and i'm jamming it in
there with 600 pounds of force against
my teeth i'm causing a lot of damage so
it's not about the strength it's more
about the motion angle your toothbrush a
little bit so that the bristles are
actually angled into the gums and you
move back and forth think about brushing
two to three teeth at a time instead of
large big strokes myth number seven
is a good one
charcoal toothpaste is better than
regular toothpaste there is no research
that suggests that charcoal toothpaste
is better than your normal fluoride
toothpaste
zero what people are kind of attracted
to about charcoal toothpaste is that it
it promotes the idea that it will whiten
your teeth people went as far as to
taking raw charcoal like just kind of
charcoal powder and brushing their teeth
with that in hopes that they were going
to like i don't know unlock a secret
whiten
tooth door
no
no no no so what can end up happening is
if you use charcoal
too much you can end up
wearing away your enamel which will then
make your teeth appear more yellow the
opposite of what you want myth eight
you have to get your wisdom teeth
removed
okay
big myth here big big big myth i know
listen man let me tell you let me tell
you you do not
have to get your wisdom teeth removed if
there is a specific reason like it's
causing you pain
the tooth now has a giant cavity the
tooth is impacted or now pushing up
against the tooth in front of it and now
it's just causing a whole drama inside
your mouth right
for a lot of people
that can be a very valid reason to have
those teeth removed and another reason
that these teeth should be removed
sometimes
is getting to those third molars by
ourselves at home and cleaning them or
these wisdom teeth can be very very
difficult if they're in line with the
others and if they're if they're
completely fine um
yeah you treat it like any other tooth
myth number nine you should brush right
after every
meal
after you eat your mouth becomes more
acidic
so it just naturally does it doesn't
matter what you eat and if you take
something mechanical like bristles and
rub it up against your enamel
in an acidic environment you can more
easily wear down your enamel and you're
doing more harm than good so what you
want to do you want to wait a little bit
you want to wait at least 30 minutes
until your mouth gets more basic more
neutral and then go in and brush
i always tell my patients
you know if you eat
and then you have food stuck
in your teeth
you're literally throwing a free buffet
to bacteria that didn't pay to get in
there myth 10
teeth grinding
is not a serious problem
a lot of people
don't know that they grind their teeth a
lot of it is you grind at night
subconsciously when you're asleep you
don't even recognize that you're doing
it so what teeth grinding does number
one it can start wearing away at the
surfaces of your teeth so if you wear
away the protective layer
now you are at a much higher risk of
having way more sensitive teeth when you
used to drink a cold glass of water
before and didn't feel anything now
there's a chance if you drink that cold
glass of water without enamel that you
may have experiences with some
sensitivity another reason that grinding
is a serious problem is that it can have
effects on our jaw if you're like me and
you're a grinder you definitely need to
get a mouth guard teeth grinding is
definitely on the rise myth number 11
gum bleeding means you should stop
flossing
do not stop flossing because your gums
bleed you got to just push through it
gum bleeding basically means
that there has been so much inflammation
around your tooth and so much potential
food stuff that's kind of stuck there
when you disturb it with the floss
your gums get angry and then they start
to bleed flossing is never going to have
a negative effect
on your oral cavity coming in hot with
myth number 12 aligners will straighten
your teeth okay
this is a very loaded question what is
the stability of their teeth how long
are they going to keep these teeth are
their gums healthy is the bone healthy
by jumping into aligners without having
that very crucial knowledge there's a
chance that when you're trying to
straighten these teeth
you could lose these teeth a good rule
of thumb for me is
if they don't take x-rays
and they want to move your teeth you
probably should not let them do that
myth lucky number 13 toothaches always
mean cavities
when you think about a cavity you think
of a small hole in your tooth that's
going to get filled with something you
don't know what the dentist does it and
then it's fixed but a toothache can be
kind of an indicator for something way
more serious so it could possibly be an
indication for
bone loss when you bite down and you're
having a lot of pain
it could be because the bone around your
tooth has started to resorb started to
disappear it can be an indication of a
fracture in your tooth myth 14
chewing gum
is just as good as brushing chewing gum
is nowhere near as good as brushing
right so chewing gum definitely has some
positive
properties okay number one if you're
going to chew gum
you want to try to chew sugar-free gum
or uh if you want to look for gum that
has xylitol in it which is a great sugar
option in your gum what that's gonna do
is it's going to promote saliva
production but for as great as chewing
sugar-free gum is it will never take
away or be a substitute for brushing
right you have to go in there with a
mechanical work toothbrush whether
electric
manual and get those surfaces of those
teeth clean and free of plaque your oral
health is a part of your overall health
so
it's not something separate like you
can't just take your mouth out and put
it someplace you have to treat it like
it's a part of your body and so daily
maintenance is crucial a lot of people
have you know dental anxiety like it
it's normal it's a lot to think about
there's so many factors that people
think about before deciding to go to a
dentist sometimes going to the dentist
to just talk
can really make a difference if you want
more information about oral health and
just best practices you can always check
out ada.org and they have tons of
resources um just type it into the
search bar and something will pop up
that can help you